you made it you made it you made it oh
yeah you made it
it you made it weird with
petees what's happening weirdos this uh
this is an incredible episode I'm so
glad you're here when uh Rich R had uh
Rabbi Finley on his podcast they called
the episode the black belt Rabbi and
that is that would be a good name if it
wasn't already taken cuz what's going on
here this is one of the most interesting
people I've ever talked to it's
fascinating it's captivating it's it's
strange it's surprising and I'm so glad
you're here it's uh it's one of those
episodes that I told Val I was like
you're going to have to listen to this
one it is uh really interesting and I'm
so glad you guys are here uh all of you
to check it out thanks for listening um
for everything Rabbi Finley cuz I I have
a feeling if you listen to this you're
going to be interested in more go to
Rabbi finley.com he mentions he teaches
some classes uh that we've been checking
out incredible just everything
everything that he's got going on is at
Rabbi finley.com as for me please watch
my please watch my
special it's on
netflix.com as my mom calls it and uh
it's called I am not for everyone I'm
also uh DC sold out thanks everybody
that's incredible I'm looking forward to
those shows we also have the Brea Improv
here in California and some other dates
uh Chicago comes to mind they're all at
pet homes.com hope to see you out there
it's a new hour not the one that's on
Netflix but the one that we be on after
that one so I hope you guys can make it
out means a lot not a lot to plug up top
uh we I just checked out my own hair
it's looking nice for those of you
watching it on the video it's looking
nice thanks thanks modern mammals uh uh
but our friends at Living Libations are
the wonderful sponsor of this podcast
you guys know this I talk about living
Libations all the time we did a complete
overhaul of our skin care teeth hair
nails baby care what is it living
Libations is basically a high-end
meaning super high quality very very
effective but natural skin hair body
Beauty teeth baby products and I for
years was being so careful about what I
put in my body but I wasn't being
careful about what I put on my body and
that makes no sense what you put on your
body ends up in your body in your system
and it's made by faceless corporations
that that just don't care about you or
your health or the toxicity of the stuff
that you're putting on your skin or in
your mouth or wherever you're putting it
so this is a great way to support not
only your body but also the show I
should have said not only the show but
also your body meaning they have big
things they have little things if you
want to uh show some support show some
love
uh to the show go to living lib.com
weird you'll get 15% off everything you
see there I love their shaving cream I
love their After Shave I use their
actually the Zen shaving cream as my
After Shave which is awesome I love
their exfoliant I love their best skin
ever moisturizer gives you like a
radiating glow but the best part is you
read the ingredients and you recognize
them as real and natural but it's
powerful it's effective and it works
better than the random chemical
nightmares they sell at 7-Eleven so do
something good for your body look good
feel good support the show living li.com
weird all right everybody I'm not for
everybody on Netflix Pete homes.com for
tour dates Rabbi finley.com for
everything related to the uh man you're
about to enjoy get into it we need these
hot takes on your beverages okay what's
the official beverage of Judaism because
there isn't one no they all have one
Christianity's
wine uh that's from that's second that's
more of a Sacrament I'm calling it the
official beverage can I you're damn
right I can you know you know it used to
be uh give us this day our daily beer
did you know that no and it was a
psychedelic beer no it's just regular
beer give us this day our daily beer
well let's get the immortality key down
and you know how they change it wait
wait oh so it wasn't bread it was beer
is this real no it's a
joke then the Bread Company came in with
a better offer you are I underestimated
you and I apologize
I forget who said the I think it was
ramdas who talked about the official
beverage he didn't call it the official
beverage but uh you know Hinduism would
be milk MH Islam I think is coffee okay
Buddhism would be tea Christianity's red
wine Judaism well I mean look at that
carefully me if that's the no no listen
it's not Islam it's the Middle East
where they first began to drink coffee
sure so if you were Christian Jewish or
Muslim you drink you drink coffee yeah I
would say tea is uh subcontinent India
and and the in the that's fair yeah so
Christianity inherits from Judaism
sacramental wine yeah and you have
sacramental wine in Judaism but I don't
think Jews are big wine drinkers what I
know right yeah and that one's taken
well it doesn't really matter we don't
we don't really think that way no I know
yeah that's very silly you know they got
the cross and that so simple you
actually can't outdo a cross right cross
is a I mean start can you imagine a star
David everywhere it's very hard to do
yeah it's got a 70s chest hair
connotation yeah just very simple two
pieces of wood like isn't the Star of
David like a sacred geometry there's
something kind of no it's all Fab made
up that's all made up yeah no I mean
someone made it up it's not sacred
geometry right but I mean are we sure
about that yeah okay don't in addition
to being a rabbi I have a doctorate in
religion social ethics and I'm a
historian and a scholar so okay so you
are sure usually when I say things I've
looked it up not not always and if I'm
not sure I like it I will say I'm not
sure well I'll tell you where my uh
resistance to that idea came up is is
whenever I'm in a temple whenever I'm in
a a a cathedral I look around and I see
a lot of the shapes that we see when we
you can close your eyes and rub your
eyes really hard you don't have to be on
a psychedelic but these images that are
associated with visions stuff like that
which is really a trip like the first
time I pun intended first time I took
mushrooms and I saw kind of like what I
would considered to be sacred geometry
or this kind of language of creation and
then I went to a cathedral I was like oh
my God they were they knew what they
were doing and that's why I was kind of
saying like even if someone made it up
couldn't they have been dipping into
that well look when you look at the the
the um architecture churches it is very
well planned out that a a a church a
cathedral especially is sacred geometry
that's very overt from the from the
designs from the very beginning yeah uh
now the Ancient Temple in Jerusalem
definitely was sacred geometry yeah the
predecessor the Tabernacle in the desert
clearly sacred geometry but there's no
evidence of a six-pointed star being
involved in any of it so the question is
you don't see any iconography you don't
see any synagogues where does the
six-pointed star make its first
appearance as official an official
Jewish uh shape yeah that's the question
right and and me saying it could be
something someone saw in a vision is
sort of moot because you could see
anything well we basically know the
people made it up and they didn't talk
about a vision right well now we're
getting into something that I think is
pretty interesting is what is making it
up mean yeah someone designed it yeah
but I mean like you like this sort of
stuff Collective unconscious like it was
there well there is a thing called main
David meaning the shield of
David uh I don't think we have kav David
the Star of David I don't I don't recall
that occurring anywhere but clearly the
Zionist movement needed a symbol yeah
and there probably some background
somewhere but it was more or less the
Zionist movement needs a symbol we need
a flag yeah and that was that was
decided upon so it might have some Roots
somewhere in Jewish history nothing
dominant that anybody else would notice
it right and where's the sacramental
wine in Judaism Shabbat for the the
Sabbath okay the Bess the blessings for
the Sabbath that makes sense I knew that
yeah yeah there's only one holiday where
we don't have a blessing over the wine
which one want you to
guess uh Russ sh no we have a blessing
over the wine aren't you fasting you
don't want wine when you're f y yamur
there you go is that what it was good
that's what I was trying to think of the
fasting one and I blew it because you
don't want to drink wine when you're
fasting you're not allowed to you're
also not allowed to yeah but that's very
so they they those come together not
allowed to not wanting to because right
which is very Jewish if I may what's
that meaning like when you look back at
some of the the the uh levitical kind of
ideas like don't eat shellfish for
example the law of kosher yeah and then
modern science kind of catches up and
goes like these things are feeding n
they're Bottom Feeders which is which is
probably the reason right uh you know uh
pork for them was probably wild boar
uhhuh uh shellfish were Bottom Feeders
the what Wild Boar is they eat garbage
eat garbage yeah so the laws of Kash
fruit you can't eat vultures you can't
eat birds that eat caring so there
really was a disgust at animals that eat
uh excrement and you know dead animals
that clearly is a part of the the the
the laws of kosher are not only found in
Leviticus but we can call them levitical
laws if you mean laws of uh Purity and
ritual as opposed to the moral laws
right yeah yeah and that is what I meant
okay you're very good sure yeah I've
been teaching this a long time I believe
it I can feel it yeah I had a friend
come to see me do stand up recently and
I have a joke about uh and it is just a
joke I was like why do we eat pigs but
we don't eat dogs no and I go I think
it's Hooves ah and I was like hooves are
the evil
feet evil feet and she said after the
show she Jewish woman she goes it's very
levitical I've never had a joke because
it's the split hoof for for an anim to
be kosher it has to have a split hoof
and chew the cut I forgot I didn't know
what she meant yeah yeah which is trying
to um set up a a taxonomy you know which
basically farm animals and and animals
you can tame yeah so they looked at all
the animals that that you could tame and
would be on your farm and those that you
would not tame and be on your farm and
they came down to what they had in
common was split Hub and and and chew
the cut okay yeah have you seen that I
believe it's in um Chinese medicine
they're like if it stands on one foot
like a plant it's like eat it all the
time two feet uh chicken they're like
eat it some of the time four feet like
they did it by feet which I thought was
very interesting where do stks fit in
STS you can flamingos strangely you can
make out with a St yeah but you can't
eat it so what so um just light making
out yeah yeah you know my wife bosses me
around a lot uhhuh and I used to do this
flamingo in um imitation she told me to
knock it off and I finally had to put my
foot
down that time I knew you were doing a
joke that's not bad right it's very good
not too bad we're getting will you speak
a little to Comedy and sure it's so
funny obviously I work in comedy yeah so
I I work with a lot of Jewish writers
producers directors obviously there's a
a cultural scope that we can't speak to
but you personally when it comes to
helping people which at the end of the
day being a spiritual teacher is I think
guiding helping in my Counseling
Practice yes counseling and and in my
teaching a lot of it is about um you
know my Niche is wisdom and inner
transformation okay and of course all
the regular things rabbis do for
counseling brief Etc but that's the main
part of my teaching and wouldn't wisdom
be
helpful yeah I think it's the most
important thing human being can learn
any human being on the face of the
planet needs wisdom and one reason
people suffer is because they don't have
wisdom right so that's I've taken that
on as my the main thing that I teach
well let's do a wisdom question and then
I'll ask you about helping people but I
was just are we rolling oh we've been
rolling this timeing okay I'm so sorry
no no no good I didn't mean it to be no
no I'm wonder I just want I want you to
miss all this great jokes that I'm
telling buddy that's the correct feeling
right I don't want it to go to waste
yeah yeah here's a wisdom question I I
was listening to obviously it's such a
heavy time right now and thank you for
taking time to be with me while all our
hearts are so heavy yeah and I listened
you know eart you know echarle I'm
assuming he gave a talk on 911 like on
the day and he didn't cancel it it's
very interesting talk it's sort of a
bside you have to be a big fan
uh but he gave a talk and everyone was
like he's going to cancel it's
911 and he he did it it's called The sun
will also die and he talks in it about
wisdom he talks about Collective
Insanity being sort of a reflection of
our personal Insanity all this stuff
it's I can't possibly summarize it he
does talk about wisdom and and this may
be why this is my wisdom question is
he's sort of like the ego is always
saying we can add something we can like
gain practice
and it puts Enlightenment or conversion
or or whatever word you'd like in the
future and it becomes another problem I
am not wise I am not holy or whatever
word and this is my question for you
it's like does wisdom take
away or does it
add well it's like mathematics does
mathematics take away or add are you
doing addition or
subtraction sure
okay the question is what the wisdom
does some ads correct I guess what I'm
saying is is the ultimate here's here's
another way to maybe frame that question
is in Judaism is the goal
to
self-realize uh it Judaism does not
contain that language but remember
self-realization is a relatively modern
term so if you by mean if we mean by
that
self-awareness mean meaning aware being
aware of how your inner life functions
minimally the consequences of your
behavior the notion that many of the
things we do don't feel like choices but
they are Ian there's a whole list of
things to be self-aware self-realization
has to do with more living out my
potential in in no in in just in in
humanistic psychology okay human
realization is part of the self is the
human potential movement that's
interesting that is not how I use it
right so self-realized which means my
potential has become real yeah okay so
you have self-actualization
self-realization these are all terms
that more or less came out of the the
German humanists and then their those
who follow them okay and to know what it
means you have to look at who's saying
it and in what
context um so if a person says I want to
fulfill my potential I said well which
potentials are we talking about because
not all of them right and we all have
the potential to be very stupid right
yeah so so ever a person says
self-realization or
self-actualization my tendency is always
to come up with very precise language
because language mediates between the
conscious and the unconscious and words
are are are there to help us understand
ourselves in reality so the more precise
we can use language the wiser we
become
interesting what language would you use
for how I mean self-realized I don't
know I have to know what you mean by it
what your goal is what your I mean how
you're using it and why you're using it
and what you hope to get out of it I
mean it in the term of realizing that
you are not the content of your life
situation you're the presence witnessing
it it's funny the in I not sure what
that means really
um the I am the awareness that you are
when you say I what do you mean it
depends on where I am and what I'm doing
if right now I am here talking to you
being present to you but when you have a
thought or a feeling what is it that's
that's seeing that ah okay so the the
awareness of self it takes a little bit
of effort to go to a state of
consciousness where you're aware of the
self yeah and it's speaking feeling
thinking I call that the The Observer
mind so when I think about human
consciousness we have an observer mind
we have an objective mind which means I
can evaluate if the way I'm observing
actually Accords with reality we have a
rational mind whether uh the way I'm
dealing with the world is is it rooted
in facts as well as we can determine
facts in good theories uh we have a
truth mind that aims at the that the
Deep truth of the matter you go beyond
that we have the love mind the beauty
mind the Justice mind the god mind so
when I think about higher Consciousness
I think about 10 10 levels of high
higher Consciousness it's just
descriptive it's just my my work and
work with other people yeah um it says
well something beyond that yeah Divine
Consciousness um you know can you
obliterate the sense of self sure it's
called meditation so I'm always
interested in is a person asking me for
my knowledge base have I figured enough
things out or they are they ask me for a
guide for a human experience so I don't
mind asking Knowledge Questions but I
get tired of them after a while okay I
would rather have a question that
someone's going to do something
with I don't mind teaching knowledge
sure but ultimately if I'm teaching a
class on Consciousness and person says
oh what about this and what about that
I'll say Okay so let's do five minutes
of you know General religious spiritual
theory on things and my take on it and
now let's get down to my class which is
human
transformation to what end though I
think there's you know it's interesting
coming from the Jewish tradition I
thought you might appreciate I do a lot
of death work in my dreams and last
night I had a dream where I was talking
to a very angry
manh and I was trying to calm him down
and I was like I feel like of course
he's
me and I'm like I feel like your anger
is coming from this despondency this
feeling that like there's this
inevitable final note we die so while
I'm all about optimizing The Human
Experience this is the same thing I
would ask Dr huberman or any of these
social scientists and Tony Robbins like
yeah let's find communication strategies
and let's look at the Sun and let's do
cold exposure and let's eat protein or
whatever it is but I think there's
something underneath that the reason why
I'm going and I started right by going
to the Observer
mind and self-realization is I'm like to
what end are we optimizing and realizing
potential and all that because the day
you die is just going to be today it
will always be today it will always be
now and your life will always have just
been the snap of a finger so I
understand that there's reducing
suffering with and I'm about that we can
have that conversation I'm just curious
about the underlying why of of that see
I I don't like to talk in generalities
because I don't speak for all Humanity
so whenever anybody says Judaism says
Americans
believe we haven't pulled everybody yeah
so if you were to ask me what's the
point of something I can give you my
point of view rooted in let's say my
understanding of Jewish and religious
sources and I'm going to have try to
come up with a something of a synthetic
view that doesn't leave most of it out
is that is that a yeah I'm just talking
to you yeah okay got it so but I'm not
speaking for anything but me and what
I've studied there you go so what you
say what does Judaism teach I'll try to
do that for you say what do I personally
believe in my personal we can all put
that aside and say let's just talk to
you more okay so so give give me your
precise question to me what is the
meaning of life okay well the meaning of
life comes down to number one do you do
your duty as you understand it at that
moment doing your duty doing your
duty that's that's that's level one so
what's interesting about that what I
hear when you say that is that the love
of
God is determined by whether or not I do
or don't do my duty yeah but I didn't
say that all I said is if you ask me
what the meaning of life is I see I have
four levels number one is we we are we
have spiritual and moral duties okay
tell me that like like a spiritual Duty
sure to create well-being within okay a
moral duty to create well-being as much
as possible with with other people okay
okay so I have to I have a duty to
create well-being uh physically mentally
morally spiritually so I have a list of
Duties to myself and to other people
don't cause other people harm benefit
them when possible um respect the person
and property of other people I think I
have a duty toward insight to myself
insight to you Insight what's happening
in this room so I have a whole list of
Duties that at any given moment what I'm
not sure what to do
examine myself examine my environment
and ask myself what my duty is at that
moment that's one thing that's one one
part of the meaning of life is
understanding what your duty is and
doing it as well as you can yeah very
cool okay the next one is find happiness
well-being we should enjoy life we enjoy
we should enjoy our our our own lives
lives with other people we should create
as much joy and happiness as we can in
general I think we have a duty to
maximize uh authentic
happiness um I think we have a duty uh
to be resilient because life can
sometimes be overwhelming and difficult
and Grievous and bad and people get
depressed people get overwhelmed they
get kind of they their life just empties
out and I've met people like that and
they say to me well why should I be
happy and look what's happening in my
life and you're saying I should do this
and you're saying I should get out of it
and I say well I think you have a
primary duty to be resilient when life
when your option is topair he said well
prove it I said it's a duty you don't
have to agree with me but for me it's a
duty it's a priori I can't empirically
prove it but you ask people ask me and
then with a Consciousness that
everything matters and everything makes
a difference sometimes the very smallest
things matter and sometimes the very
smallest things make a difference so
always be you know kind of aware where
you are attuned to where you are um
adaptive accountable but always look for
things that because of the way
Consciousness is driven by being attuned
to one thing or another that you might
miss something crucial so we in martial
arts we call it 360 awareness so even as
I am attuned to something which is a
good thing I should cultivate a kind of
moral and spiritual 360 awareness so for
me that's how I that's the meaning of my
life how I create meaning of life and
every everything comes after that which
means my life is constructed from that
then everything comes next that reminds
me of of the story of uh it's one of
those monk stories there's a and his
teacher and his teacher came up to him
while the student was walking in the
garden and he hit him with a stick he
like what was that he's just like Jesus
says something similar he's like wait
for God like you wait for a burglar to
come into your house and that is like a
a vigilance that you just reminded me of
yeah so in in Jewish spiritual
psychology it's something called zirut
which means ongoing
awareness so yeah so as I'm sitting
talking to you okay I also have a sense
of every now and then take a breath and
have 360 awareness where I am what's
going on yeah right what's the quickest
way out of here yeah what can I kill
somebody with you know what do you got
huh I mean well you got some nice things
right over here in front of me I could
just hit somebody with these tripods
yeah that's place to start those are
Hollow boned I don't know well you can
poke somebody with it I believe you
could yeah no it's funny Dane Cook has a
funny bit about that where he's like uh
I believe it was after 9911 I think
that's important context he's like we're
all scared on airplanes and one on my on
an airplane now I'm like something goes
down I'll break the CD in half and I'll
have two knives and I was like that's
pretty good creative thinking yeah it's
you know when when you work in martial
arts a long time and you realize that in
any second your life or the life of
another innocent a loved one could be in
danger yeah
and ideally don't be uh surprised into
an action more than a second surprised
into in action so freeze basically yeah
exactly yeah yeah so you train yourself
to
respond okay so that's what a lot of
martial arts is stimulus provides
immediate response wow to get that sort
of pause away not only God might be
knocking right the devil might be
knocking yeah anybody could be knocking
yeah so that so that's when I talk about
being you know having awareness now
sometimes we go into fug States we
Daydream you we that's that's part of
human consciousness and that's how we
enjoy our lives and work things out but
there's a part of a person that should
be relatively aware going on around them
in addition to whatever else is going
on um so um yeah I think you know part
of martial arts is being you know 360
awareness including if I had if I had to
defend if if if I had a role in
defending this room at this moment yeah
what would I do right I have to be I
walk into a room that's one thing I
think I get out of my car I think about
it have you been
attacked when I was yeah yeah I grew up
in comptent you know that so oh you did
oh I didn't know that have a whole
history of that so that is that what got
you interested in martial arts um just
about positive just about positive yeah
I mean not everybody's martial arts oh
just about positive you're just about
POS I'm nearly positive yeah but I don't
want to claim to complete
self-standing nobody understands thes
completely right I feel like you're on
the stand or something like you can't
hold me to that I can't say their you
see I'm I'm a lifelong teacher and I say
something people raise their hand and do
you know the 15 chambers of the
unconscious I say fine I'm reasonably
sure that's why you can't say this but I
can say this sounds like some of your
students are [__] well they're not
my students but they're [__] they
attend my classes which is a far
different than be my student and who's
who's coming to these class not students
when I would just you know teach a class
anybody could sign up for my class I see
and then I have what I call my students
which are people who are studying with
me one way or another and staying in the
program I understand and some of them
are
some of them none of mine no they can't
be my student of mine what do you they
can attend my class yeah the the people
who some of the people who attend your
class yeah are not are not nice people
thank you anybody sued so anybody I take
on as a student is by definition at
least respectful other people they're
not all nice people yes like I'm not a
nice person but I'm respectful of people
right I'm going to just real quick get
my next question to you notorized
okay Katie would
you well how does martial arts and and
your how does it how does it benefit
your life I I have a feeling there's a
rich appreciation of it you're a black
belt correct and I'm
wondering other than self-defense has it
just kind of filled your life with a
direction like it feels like a I mean
the direction of I love doing it I love
training I love the club I love the guys
for me it's somebody else doing dance or
doing music it's my dance music
camaraderie yeah so I I love every part
of it but that 360 awareness doesn't
that not only protect you but also imbue
you with appreciation for the present
moment well I would say yes except I
also have that for my spiritual study so
there are many people who cultivate a
spiritual 360 awareness in our martial
artist yeah and many martial artists
have 360 self-defense awareness but they
don't have a 360 right spiritual
awareness but they inform each other
yeah in my case they would certainly
inform each other yeah and when you do a
contemplative walk or whatever uh you
call it just a thought a mindful walk
walk do you feel that hey since I've
been doing I know you've been doing it a
long time but that your martial arts
training is sort of informing that well
uh that's an interesting question if I'm
going to be involved in anything
spiritual and spiritual I would probably
I'd rather be sitting because because I
live in a neighborhood with a lot of
automobiles and pedestrians and dogs and
I've actually almost walked into people
so and they've almost walked into me so
because you're kind of in a state
exactly so I prefer to be I would be I
would focus when I walk or run I'd
rather be in an awareness that I'm on
the street there are cars there are
people yeah there are dogs I would
rather be aware of my surroundings now
I'm also aware of the sunrise and the
flowers and the beauty yeah but not to
the point that I'll run into somebody
else knock him down right that that's
just common sense right of course yeah
have you had Transcendent experiences
I'm assuming I would say many yes yeah
what is what's one that comes to mind
that kind of got you hooked well the I
mean the most frequent is when I do a
meditative practice um the dominant
meditative contemplative practice I have
is is what in Judaism is called the
practice of a holy words so you meditate
on a word that that has a holy resonance
and you hold it in Consciousness and you
get everything out except the holy word
um it's as if the holy word has its own
gravity and it Roots itself into the
unconscious ego self and drills down
into the realm of the soul and there's a
dialogue that goes on between the soul
and Consciousness through the through
the um the medium of the holy word and
some I to be a holy phrase um I love
studying poetry for example so I would
call those in
intentionally created experiences where
I transcend day-to-day Consciousness if
if that's what your question is it
reminds me of the the monkey mind idea
that it's like you have a monkey in your
brain and then you give them a pile of
buttons and you say move these buttons
from this side to this side and the
button might be the word yeah that is a
um not exactly there is a
technique to uh give Consciousness a
hook like a behind the door to put the
jacket on yeah while you're moving into
the state for people who can't control
the so the the monkey mind MH so you get
it something to think about well this is
more than that and this is assume you've
actually been able to tame the monkey
for a while now so you don't
have you don't have the problem with the
monkey mind as soon as you decide not to
as soon as I say I'm going to to do my
holy word practice the monkey the monkey
just gets quiet and just stands in the
corner because you've done it enough
because I've been doing it for my Mo
most of my adult life yeah yeah I guess
we could say that pathway has been
grooved exactly exactly you got you got
to train the monkey once the monkeyy
trained you just keep the monkey trained
yeah I love that yeah I if I were your
monkey I'd be terrified yeah no no my my
monkeyy is scared of me I will say let
me ask icy yeah he's terrified I just I
just asked he goes yeah I'm not I'm not
messing with you man I'm just like I'm
trying to stay out of your way I said
okay just stay right there I'm but
that's the thing I'm picking up is you
seem very disciplined and and like and
uh proactive uh uh definitely proactive
as disciplined as I can be and remember
there's always something in you that
does not want to be disciplined which is
why we call it discipline right right
right yeah I remember I watched I think
it was Paul Redd talked about how he got
his Ant-Man body and he said his uh
trainer was just like you'll never want
to do it and the whole secret is just do
it anyway it's that is discipline do
what you don't want to do and I know
even as you say it I'm like it's so
obvious but I my monkey it might be just
more persu maybe I'm just I don't know I
need to build that muscle even more yeah
there are ways to deal with it because
um in Judaism it's called the yeter har
yeter means shape or form it's come to
mean urge but that's not what it means
it means a shape or form the word ra
means evil or destructive
so it's as if the unconscious ego self
has a destructive shape there's part of
the puzzle is destructive they want it
wants to undo well we both have uh
Steven prfi the resistance that's how he
I met because I was calling it yah har I
read his book and I was giving a talk on
this and some and I mentioned his book
and someone told him but he started
taking my class oh wow and um so then I
read his book and we became friends
we're still friends and exactly he's
wonderful yeah but he also n see there's
a benefit I
think eart I sometimes asked children my
daughter had a tantrum yesterday at the
zoo and one of the things that CI says
is like after they're calm you can go
does it have a shape like that feeling
is can you paint it can you talk about
it and there is something about
depersonalizing and
detaching and when I read Stephen's book
which I've read many times but it was
like I find a lot of value in going
there it is resistance or the say it
again the yeter yeter har har yeah so
the yeter har or the resistance or the
pain body or whatever it is this yeah
it's think of it as a quasi external
intelligence that does not share your
vision for yourself and will work
actively against it
wow hardcore yeah it is it's always at
work and it doesn't want you to be
fulfilled and Stephen pressfield would
say that like this leads to
pain in circumstantial pain it can lead
to disease it's just like a stuck
blocked it it
can um his book is more about
procrastination and avoidance of your
work yeah um however um if if you don't
fight with it and it's not morbid which
means it won't just have you sit on the
couch and eat fast food every day a
person can get through their whole life
not you know just go to work um get the
job done if it if if it comes natural to
them
be an okay parent as long as they're not
verbally or physically abusive be an
okay life partner and just get through
this thing and and dies because they're
not working on anything right now let
minut you begin to work on something and
then you hit something that's not
easy okay so that's the part some things
come natural to people yeah and then you
actually have to have to um bring it up
to a level of not just talent but skill
so then you run into resistance and this
is what by the way is what we see in
Jiu-Jitsu um there are people come in
there are natural athletes they're fast
they're strong they're they're just good
with their hands with their body their
Mobility so they move up pretty quick
they get to the the blue belt level
which means you've mastered the basics
and then getting from Blue to purple is
where most people drop really because no
one gets to Purple belt intuitively you
just have to train and you have to get
rid of some really bad habits it's the
just do it part it's the do it and train
hard this is very similar to comedy
believe it or not I'm not an athlete but
there's
a I'll put this to you and see what this
makes you think of sometimes people say
to me they go you know I did stand up
eight years ago and I've really been
wanting to get back into it and I'm
always like just don't like it didn't
get you it didn't gra you and that's
okay yeah but like I think you're
conflating like standup with success or
fame or money and I'm like that's
actually not what it is no it's a
profound skill I love stand up oh you do
oh I love stand up you're good I appreci
much thank you very much but I I have my
my favorites and I watch their shows my
my few favorites I probably watch their
shows at least 20 times really yeah and
I'm watching everything they do wow
who's a fav right now Bill Burr yeah I
love Bill Burr he's one of the greats
yeah I love uh Jessel Nick yeah
Chappelle is the is the you know is the
Emperor yeah so you know and then I'll
I'll watch a few others but when I
really want to look at
the I think the most
uh deceptive of all of them is Bill Burr
yeah what do you mean because he makes
it look like he's just free associating
out of control you know emotionally
coming apart yeah it is so well done you
don't know you are you're watching a
genius play Mozart on his viol no he's a
master yeah and he uh I was very lucky
he was one of the first people I opened
for when I was in my first 5 years of
standup and then we stayed in touch and
he just produced my special that's
coming out yeah so he's been a huge part
of my life and I actually watch his
biggest fan is sitting across I love
that well you'll appreciate I I can't
tell you what you'll appreciate see
you're rubbing off on me but um I think
you'll appreciate that he wasn't always
Bill bur there was a time when he was
just a great Club comic and when he
started headlining people were kind of
like really a little bit and he he went
from Blue to purple because of a
compulsion and because of uh whatever
the anti yet that yeah so that we we
would call that discipline discipline
yeah so the the yetsa is always trying
to have us not fulfill our potential
yeah and then it's clever it's strong
but it's not wise so a the way to defeat
the yahar well what you just said was
incredible it's clever it's strong and
it's but it's not Wise It's clever and
strong but it's not wise I just needed
you to say it again cuz that was to be
fast I put a lot of work into coming
enough with that because I would meet
people at the the most clever and strong
yet har because it has slogans it has
speeches that are very convincing yeah
well don't I get to say what I think
yeah
no you get to say what doesn't make
things worse wow wow well I have a right
to speak politically you have a right to
speak but not with your spouse you don't
have a right to speak in fact you have a
duty to shut up so this just because
people have all these like memes running
in their heads that just license the
most atrocious and and and and silly
Behavior those examples were Thea
interpersonally like rubbing off on
someone else or I'm tired today yeah
yeah yeah that's that's for you yeah
yeah yeah yeah and don't don't I just
you know it's so
funny the voice of like I was just
talking about I don't drink anymore and
I but I sometimes go to bed without
brushing my teeth and I go it's the same
thing pretty much it's liberty it's it's
it's
close people laugh you know it's a silly
idea but I go I'm telling you it's no
one tells me what to do it's from the
yah for sure tell me yeah so brushing
your teeth is the yet saying I just need
something symbolic I don't have to
follow the rules I said if that's what
you need once a month for you to feel
strong take it yeah yeah yeah a
concession I'll give you that it goes
okay that's all I need I said fine now
shut up for a months I get all my life
however right if it says I need a drink
now now we're at War well my answer I
used to say you work at night get drunk
sober up then do your show I was like
was running your life he was he was
running your life and I was overweight
and I was all these different things and
it's just it's I didn't know this is the
conversation I needed to have but it's
like it's so nice to like we were saying
label
it and you said a partially external
quasi external quasi external because it
doesn't once you get to a level of
conscious you realize it is not I right
there's an authentic self trying to live
my life and sudden you realize that
there's an alternative self inside of
you that has a contrary Vision to what
your life should be right and it and it
says
deceptive I mean it's mendacious it's
deceptive it runs on slogans it be very
convincing it's strong until you wise up
and you say oh you're there yeah you're
always awake right okay and whatever I
do in my life I got to deal with you
most of
all okay so that's so funny that that
energy gets RIT large in society when
you're talking about slogans unwise
correct when you start
realizing that food companies or
beverage compan or alcohol companies or
they don't care about you or political
parties or political parties everybody
runs on slogans because they don't want
you to think because if we thought yeah
we wouldn't really I don't think we
would belong to a political party if we
thought I agree you would just say of
all of them this represents my interest
the best but just be aware they are also
doing things that are really wrong for
sure and then and say and vote your
conscience but don't ever
assume that for any any party get
elected they got to come up with slogans
yeah that the slogans name the
complexity of the problem because life
is complex yeah so I would say
everything runs on slogans from the
yeter to politics to well parents
parents sometimes which is why I'm
against SL I teach a lot of parent cours
I'm the middle of run right now that
people say is lifechanging people tell
me their parenting has Chang 180 degrees
from my course because one thing I have
parents do is not think in slogans yeah
that's exactly so right on so where I
was thinking meaning
I feel like our presidents are often our
parents it's the ritualistic reenactment
of a trauma that's familiar to us so
you're looking at a face shape you're
looking at like a a voice all these
things it's like casting a movie you're
casting somebody and you don't realize
it looks like the first girl you fell in
love with and it had nothing to do with
their talent and then you you're [__]
because they stink that hasn't happened
to me I'm just saying that could happen
same thing with
a raising my daughter so complicated and
and we stay away from SL Lans in fact we
just learned don't say maybe
neurologically maybe is a very
destructive word when of my daughters
says can we get ice cream and you say
maybe I feel like you'll appreciate this
I just go no M or or yes but yes but
sure yes but not today yeah yeah yeah oh
I like that yeah I think kids you should
teach a course on should teach a course
well I do say no because we got ice
cream on Friday yeah there you go so yes
but not until Friday they like to hear
yes yeah yeah that's really good for
their brains which means I'm not
stopping you in your agency to fulfill
your life yeah because we're in charge
of them yeah I really want ice cream yes
but not till Friday as opposed to no
right not till Friday powerful so simple
yeah and when you think of it as your
brain uh Dr Hu was talking about when
you say maybe it's received exactly the
same as a yes and and then this is this
tripped me out that the brain releases
and starts a uh I guess it would be a
dopamine response yeah it's very
deceptive so I I when when I'm thinking
maybe I say let me think about it let me
think about it let think I said I'm not
sure let me think about it yeah that's
nice and that I think that really puts
them in exactly where I want them to be
yeah so he will say you're in my Lial
space exactly I'm defining and they say
we'll think about it now I said no I'm
going to think about it later well why
not now because I'm going to think about
it later I love this I I I've just
trying to find the right first of all
Leela is an only child so I sort of like
messing with her meaning IAD last french
fry and just be like like we were
playing a game last night you you
couldn't meet a more tender that's a
weird compliment to give myself I'm just
so patient and loving and gracious and
generous with my I'm sure you're a
fabulous Dad thank you very much and I
had a little spice every once in a while
playing a game and I and I got it before
she did and she and she was like Hey and
you know when she was a little younger
maybe I would have but now she's five
and I'll be like you were too slow there
you go that's the game it's fun it's fun
exactly what's fun is Dad's Rascal and
you have to exactly yeah so that's
exactly our our yeah child rearing has
been based on jokes and
pranks wait ours my wife and I yeah okay
tell me jokes and pranks jokes and
pranks tell me what you mean what's a
joke or a prank that you do to your
children uh they get from the table I
hide their
plate this is a synchronicity cuz our
daughter's in a monory school and and
they were we had a parent night where
they were like let's you know blend the
home and the classroom and the teacher
uh the older kid teacher who we haven't
really we don't know him very well yet
his name is Michael he was like you know
you're supposed to put your shoes in a
certain place and sometimes they don't
and instead of like hey you know like
that like the the
peanuts he'll just take them and put
them on top of the water cooler just a
joke and there is if we're really
unpacking it I think there's a slight
appropriate shaming of like you didn't
know where to put it you know what I
mean just just enough salt in the recipe
to be like look at your dumb shoes
they're up on the cooler now you know
what I mean right not cruel but but you
were too slow it's minor it's minor
deconstructing reality yes where if
you're not going to put the right place
we'll put it in a really night right
place yeah and the kid will be able to
say that's exactly where they should be
thank you and then then you realize oh
no this kid has upped it to a whole
other level that I didn't even think of
that and that is is the Machan genius
child that's like thank you that's where
I'd like them you thank you so much yeah
shoes on the water I got a song
coming you're helping me realize that
Leela is very smart I think she's High
process I think she's wonder I think she
also a little scattered and I she's like
Dad basically but we get in uh we get
jammed up when I notice that she's
unpacking logic like that water thing
that didn't happen but that's exact when
kids go I see what we're doing and I'm
okay with it exactly so that that's
great so I think for us part of one of
the jobs of parenting is to constantly
deconstruct reality yeah and by the way
that's a big part of Jewish humor yeah I
mean the meaning Yiddish humor so Jews
from other ethnic groups don't have what
the Yiddish humor has which is of course
it's a thinning out because of our
contact with the Yiddish culture is of
course as Generations go by is not as
strong but Yiddish humor was very much
surreptitious deconstructive cynical
edgy coming from an angle and that's one
of the functions of humor well that's
like that dumb joke I texted you which I
got from Romas or I emailed it to you
but I've told a million times maybe we
can use it as an example it's the rabbi
is's going to Temple it's Saturday
policeman says where you going Rabbi he
says I don't know oh right he says
clearly you're going to Temple and he
goes I don't know uhhuh he reminds me of
you uhhuh yeah he reminds me of you I
didn't realize how right on the nose I
was I'm a much higher level yes of
course you are but he's he's going like
I don't know the eight quadrants of the
or whatever it is and he goes the
policeman gets irate and throws the
rabbi in prison and the prison and the
rabbi goes see so that is a
deconstruction of reality and and
reality is funny yeah buddy the funniest
joke is ready after this I have another
podcast that's hilarious that's nonsense
and we're all living in this I actually
don't know why that's funny cuz I I'll
tell you because I don't know what's
going to happen oh I see you're right
it's the same thing as the rabbi or
or I don't know it's all sort of funny
acting like we know what's happening and
we understand it and that's what I do
with my daughter so so okay so let let
me unpack that that joke for you um if
he says where are you going so this now
the rabbi is more Zen yeah which is why
R like yeah the rabbi would answer it
with a question yeah why are you asking
he says Reb where you going Define
going that's what that's what the
Yiddish Rabbi would say Define going
yeah because now you put the cop into a
state of aoria which is I don't know
yeah so if I say what do you mean by
going I'd say moving towards that
building the cop would be stunned from
it right yes which is great yeah cuz
you're going to ask me an obvious
question yeah I'm going to put you into
a state of Unknowing that reminds me of
another one my friend do you know Rob
Bell he's he's a spiritual author he's
he's wonderful he tells a joke I believe
it was a rabbi and a
centurion and uh the Centurion says he's
walking where he shouldn't be and the
Centurion says um who are you and what
are you doing here and the Rabbi says
meet me here every day and ask me those
two questions like like we're off to a
good start like let's talk that seemed
like another yeah kind of yishi joke
yeah that's that I would call that an
Insight joke yeah but yish jokes always
have a kind of a turn the tables tell me
what's one oh there's a a very famous
okay I was just going to say no pressure
it doesn't have to be good just Old
Country yeah so two Jews are walking
down the street and they out in front of
the Catholic Church it says um um any
Jew who converts a thousand
rubles so they
go okay um so uh which one of us goes in
goes well you go in and I'll I'll wait
out here kind of watch the door yeah so
he goes in comes back out and he says uh
so did you get the money he goes is that
all you people think about that is a
great joke is that a great joke that is
a great joke wow it took my breath away
like I didn't laugh just sort of like I
ingested that's a great joke so that's
an inside joke yeah there's so much you
have to know to understand that joke
sure and then but I also appreciate what
it says about identity and as soon as
you belong to another group you like and
you even adopt yeah the US them yeah so
that joke is so sophisticated so many
levels yeah yeah so so yish jokes um I
mean you know the Yiddish curse uh may
you win the lottery and spend it all on
a
dentist that's a Twist yeah yeah yeah
yeah so yish humor always has that
little bite at the end yeah yeah yeah
wow okay all right my my I I certainly
know a few hundred Jewish jokes yeah and
the authentically Jewish joke always has
a little bit of a sharp and this is why
I I was I don't want to say impressed
what's the word I was uh appreciative
that your favorite
Comics I come from the Evangelical God
help me the Evangelical Christian
tradition I'm not tell yeah well it's my
face it's the official logo of the face
the guy help me part oh there you
go but we we my tradition is like if you
liked a comedian well if you're going to
say especially if you're a pastor you
have to say a clean one you have to
that's just that's rule number one this
is a dark statistic but I remember
hearing that like when there'd be like a
youth pastor conferences in the 80s um
and they'd all be staying in the same
hotel that the porn ordering the porn
would like
Skyrocket and I hear that and I'm like
of course it's the only time like the
shadow isn't
to use Jacob it's not wrestled with it's
it's not a Down andout
Dirty debate let's well what if God
isn't omnipresent it's not like that
it's more like these are the things you
don't question I'm certainly not horny
I'm definitely not angry what are you
[__] nuts I'm not angry and I don't
like hearing people talking about their
ding-dongs or whatever it is and
something I always admired and I'd love
to hear your take on this and now we are
talking I guess about
Judaism but I admire I I admired the
earthiness of of Judaism that it was
more like look at Job look at Jonah look
at look at the let's talk about it
instead of the Crest Smile I don't think
Jesus is saying let's all pretend
everything's hunky dory but I do think
we turned it some of us turned it into
the religion of poity my homeboy Richard
Roar always says the word nice is
nowhere in the New Testament not one
doesn't say nice but we turned it into
like be nice like nice things yeah turn
the other cheek those kinds of things
turn the other yeah just kind of be
chill be chill and I looking over the
fence as it were I'd always look at my
Jewish friends and and Jewish teachings
that I appreciated I was like it seemed
to be earthy and a little more in touch
with maybe more
honest I would say more honest to The
Human Condition yeah let's put it that
it's not it's not trying to sand down
the human condition to be in offense
right so the the Hebrew Bible fully
confronts The Human Condition I will say
that as I've taught for example job the
Garden of Eden story there there has
been a
tendency to theologize these stories and
make the character saintly when I think
there's actually a lot more darkness and
shadows in these stories so so that's
part of what I'm doing and many people
find it
upsetting but I'm taking my cue from
Tomic literature and Jewish humor which
is look for the shadow look for the edge
so I'm just taking it back to the Bible
and then people ask me my interpretation
of for example the Garden of Eden which
I call the House on Haunted Hill and
people say well can you justify that I
say open the text and we read the text
they say oh that means this that means
that I said how do you know that's what
it means yeah how about we just say what
it says yeah for example yeah please
tell me um the snake says um uh to Eve
um something like
uh did God not tell you that when you
eat from it uh you will die or or she
says he says so I have my Bible here why
can't I eat from and the snake says
something that God said yeah okay and
God s says no that's not going to happen
in fact your eyes will become open
you'll be you you will become wise yeah
okay isn't it as he is no uh something
we can look it up yeah the snake clearly
was hang out in Genesis chapter 2 if
that happened in Genesis Chapter
3 The Snake was present at that
conversation where God said those things
yeah oh that's interesting I've never
this is very Jewish and I love it I love
this stuff well it should be Jewish
except except I don't hear I've never
heard anybody teach it that way yeah but
is Jewish in looking for the Unseen
right what was implied yeah yeah not
even implied not implied because people
have missed it I've never seen one
biblical commentator say Obviously the
snake was there right in Genesis chapter
2 right because he couldn't quote God
how was he quoting him yeah exactly
secondly the snake is telling the truth
because they touched the tree and they
didn't die wow so the snake is telling
the truth God was not telling the truth
yeah let's start there right okay um so
people say oh no what God meant is when
God
said on the day you eat from you shall
die it says oh he meant they became
mortal I said but that's not what the
Hebrew says the Hebrew says on the day
you eat from it you will die right and
they look at they go yeah that's what it
says I said did it happen no did the
snake tell them it wouldn't happen see
okay my own Rabbi goes what what is the
word day I want to unpack day there you
go well it's called reading but the Pat
the before you have to go to the
metaphoric level let's just deal with
the simple level that's how language is
communicated yeah so he could say Day
means a thousand years but then then
what is God communicating see they what
they want to say is you will become
mortal but then that takes the whole
Edge out of the story I mean the way you
read a story is to read it with the
greatest depth and the greatest quality
or the greatest humor to say when you
eat from it you'll become
mortal um like a thousand years a
million years I'll take it right yeah
you're going to give me a million years
I'll become I'll be wise for a million
years or clueless forever I'll take I'll
take wise for a million years oh wow but
you see iterates the story yeah but if
the story is God says on the day you eat
from it you will die and the snake says
no you won't you're absolutely right now
we have a story the laws of a joke you
can't say he means in couple hundred
years that's ruin you just ruin we're at
a dinner and I go honey you just ruin
you stepped on my punchline God has to
say you're going to die yeah for the
snake to be funny for the story to be
funny the whole thing to work yeah for
the whole thing to work I agree so
that's how that's how I read the story
wow I love that the reason I went day
was God being outside of time here I am
we're at the temple and I'm like I I'm
not allowed in I'm sitting at the step
but if God is outside of time meaning
Eternal meaning timeless
he sees it all happening instantaneously
there's no joke there man S no I agree I
agree no you're absolutely what
everybody does with it everybody says oh
God's times said but there's a joke and
it's a dark joke yeah and the dark joke
is God's ambushing people yeah what kind
of God ambushes people yeah the god of
job yeah are you saying that the god of
job is hovering in the in Genesis yes
that's exactly what I'm saying yeah and
people are horrified and Jonah too uh
Joon Jonah I would put a little bit a
little bit differently because I think
that's the author of Jonah playing with
the audience oh interesting yeah I I'm I
always think that Jesus says people ask
for a sign and he says the only sign
I'll give you is the sign of Jonah which
I thought is pretty badass what's the
sign of Jonah meaning you're going to
get eaten by a giant fish like like if
you you're looking to me for like a
flashy show you need to understand the
joke there yeah tell I tell no that's
why I'm bringing it up okay so when When
God says to Jonah go to Nineveh and
prophesy first of all I can't even get
our own people to do what you want why
should I go to
them right help me understand that Jonah
is in not Nineveh he's in in the land of
Israel okay and they say go to Nineveh
and propes yep like don't go to
Jerusalem and don't go oh I see I'm
failing in Israel but you're telling me
to go to another go yeah yeah yeah and
like it's already not working and he
says why should I do he think why should
I do that so what the what the prophet
normally says at this point is you know
I'm I'm of unclean lips I can't do it
I'm not worthy Jonah goes straight to
Joff and gets on a boat wow okay and you
think that would be rewarded though get
running to off getting on a boat being
like God said it I'm going to do it no
he's Nineveh is that way the boat is
that way oh the boat's going the other
way I miss okay I'm all so he says go to
Nineveh go to go to yeah Israel to to
Baghdad yeah and he jumps on a boat to
Greece I see I understand the joke okay
um I'm tracking the joke yeah okay so a
storm breaks out and the sailors are God
is angry with us and it says the sailors
are Pious and and and are God-fearing
but who's down in the hold the defiant
Prophet who's causing the
the storm yeah so they're trying to
figure out which one of us is causing
the storm they finally find out is the
is the Hebrew Prophet who's hiding down
like under the bags of rice whatever
yeah they pull him out they throw him
overboard so this the storm stops now he
he quotes a metaphor from Psalms that
says oh I am drowning in the in the in
the you know in the depths of the sea
which is always a metaphor for the
spiritually drowning person except he's
really drowning right okay so it itself
is probably a metaphor but yeah no it's
a joke it's a joke okay so if I if I
take the metaphor of I'm drowning in my
sorrows but at the bottom of the ocean
but it's actually happening it's a joke
actually happening so he's reifying the
metaphor which is funny right I see okay
yes then a whale comes and swallows them
and we realize okay now we've gotone to
the ridiculous right and so now he's
writing his his ode inside of of of a
big fish right right so now it's gone to
really to the ridiculous and then God
says you got to go where I tell you to
go spits them out H okay so he goes okay
fine so he goes all the way to Nineveh
and he says four words arim y Nineveh NE
pocket 40 days Nineveh overthrown not
Isaiah chapter after chapter after not
not Jeremiah yeah these long winded
fulminating prophets four words wow all
of Nineveh
repents everybody puts on sackcloth and
Ashes even the cows and even the
chickens wow so what is the you
understand it's yeah I mean they're
making fun of
penitent they dress up their cows and
sackcloth and Ashes and the chickens so
that's a joke too you're you you
couldn't find a better example for
someone who's listening to it through
the past because you're telling it to me
in a new way and I keep going so he was
a success and you're going no it's a
joke it's a joke it's a complete joke
it's a farce no Prophet say for words
right and nobody nobody repents anyway
right and you don't dress up your cows
and chickens in sackcloth and Ashes
right so it's it's all a joke from
beginning to end it's a joke it's
not my brain just instantly does this
Jonah suffered and once you suffer and
are baked in that Kiln you can convert
people with for words you can do God's
work and quickly you see how that yeah
totally I kind of westernized it yeah so
yeah so you become Iron Man no many many
people have this tendency when you say
Bible God they spiritualize it and they
don't allow the Bible to be Wicked and
funny and stitious because they
spiritualize everything into a kind of a
yes kind of a whitebred banality yeah so
I said let it let it be Wicked right Let
It Be Clever Let It Be undermining okay
so I think the many parts of the stories
of the Bible are profoundly undermining
yes now going back disruptive they're
disruptive so now they're getting into
where humor happens is in the deepest
parts of the unconscious see it plums
you into the unconscious it unsettles
you like a dream exactly and once you
get the
joke you become wiser see only a wise
clued in person can get the joke
right is this I feel like I'm going to
ask the wrong question I'm not afraid to
ask the wrong question but I am
protecting Myself by saying is this the
wrong question what is the joke here how
do how do you interpret the joke of
Jonah the joke is a joke on Prophecy
because prophecy is the most solemn
austere respected institution in aged in
Israel and says someone says I have a
joke for you about
prophets and you have a joke about a
prophet yeah and he tells the joke and
people are screaming oh my God you hit
every solemn Trope of a prophet yes
right you undid every single one of them
in one little story wow that I mean it's
a brilliant burlesque yeah it is a
burlesque I I'm you're wow veils fall
off my eyes it's very interesting so why
do we have it well why not have some
burlesk in the Bible yeah yeah why not
make fun of prophets but isn't it a
shame look maybe it's not a shame just
is what it is that we turn it
into you know what Jonah has become what
job has become yeah heg geography so
that's where I find into resistance
because I'm after the truth what was the
word you used the resistance that people
have hey the study of saints I see so
it's a joke he's not a saint he's a joke
yeah right he's a prophet who's the butt
of a joke let's not let's not make the
guy a saint just let's let me just tell
the joke right right
so because I'm interested as you in
yungi and thought the nature of the
unconscious the nature of humor in the
unconscious and the idea that the
greatest philosophers are comedians
because ComEd a good comedian
relentlessly goes to the heart of the
matter breaks it open and we laugh
because a it's funny and B because we're
uncomfortable and a new truth has been
revealed to us and the the experience is
laughter and oh crap he just said
something true that I laughed at and now
by my laughing I know it's true and I've
just been exposed to everybody in this
room that I know what the truth is you
just described Bill Bird too yeah right
and jck and Jess Nick sure I don't I
don't agree with that I'm just kidding I
love Jess Nick as well the reason I was
sticking with Burr was I remember um oh
man Val my wife was side stage with me
at Largo and Bill was on stage and Bill
was doing a joke about Hillary Clinton
and he was like why does she get to be
the president CU she's the wife of a
president it's like if somebody I'm
going to butcher it but if somebody
comes to fix my sink right and then he
stops and goes you know what my wife's
going to take over I'd be like get the
[__] out of
here that's fine that's just a joke what
was crazy was V was laughing her ass off
and it's like being naked it's like it's
an exposed like I look I can't speak for
Val I'm learning from you but I can say
in that moment I was laughing and I was
like it's interesting I at the very
least he exposed an
unexamined endorsement that that you
know you know what I'm saying like it's
untable men are thinking and women won't
permit men to think there that's the
yeaha there you go and so now she
laughed she goes I just admitted I know
what men are thinking cuz she said I
don't get it yeah that's right right she
recognized a shadow thought there you go
so that's what jokes do yes they break
through the shadow but this is my I I
sorry they break through the shadow and
bring us the truth that's
right this episode is brought To Us by
our friends at ritual the makers of the
best multivitamin that I have ever found
the essential for men which I take every
single day as well as the best pre-
poost and probiotic allinone called the
symbiotic plus that I also take every
day these are pills that I never miss I
take them I travel with them I love the
way it makes me feel ready to start my
day the biggest concern I hear about
multivitamins is that you just pee it
out that's that's something I've been
hearing since the'80s it's like you take
it you just pee out like highlighter
colored pee and that's how you know it's
not working well ritual has a delayed
release they fixed it first of all it
has a minty Essence so it tastes great
while you're taking it two it delays
release until it's in your large
intestine where the uh nutrients can
actually be absorbed which is huge so no
Predator blood pee and just anecdotally
I go to my doctor years ago they were
like you're deficient this this and this
and this ritual help me filled those
gaps and made a noticeable difference uh
I love it I swear by it and you know you
can talk about fantasy football with
your friends but not so much uh
multivitamin health so that's what I'm
here for ritual takes the guesswork out
of the vitamin game they multivitamin
from men is based on science to help
fill those gaps as I mentioned and uh
level up your nutrient goals it's an
allaround win it's traceable it's vegan
friendly like I said it's a delayed
release makes it gentle on an empty
stomach I do a lot of fast in doesn't
disrupt your stomach but gives you that
omega-3 DHA gives you the immune support
from D3 it's incredible it's it's so
much in one little thing that you can do
to make a big difference in your in your
daily routine essential for men is a
quality multivitamin from a company you
can actually trust and get this ritual
is offering weirdos 30% off 30% your
first month visit ritual.com weird to
start ritual ritual or add essential for
men to your sub subscription today
that's ritual.com
weird all right everybody back to Rabbi
Finley bring us through the shadow see
this is my whole break the shadow they
break the grip of the Shadow I can't
wait to tell you this okay great I can't
wait to to hear it
yeah so at that parenting meeting Val
and I talk a lot
about uh the world and and and I guess
we could just say evil how how for me to
have this you don't have it uh for me to
be sitting here you're not sitting here
just basic stuff like we all take that
for granted and when you're raising a
daughter a child you know you watch
their cartoons there's no conflict or
the conflict is very minimal their music
is very da da da da and there's just an
incubation period of like everything's
fine everything's fine fine and there's
something grotesque about that truly
it's very easy to skewer that and parody
that it's I hear a lot of people being
Coco Coco melon is like a fever dream
cuz we know it's unnatural it's like the
Matrix where they said we made the first
Matrix a Utopia but people kept
rejecting it and and dying it's it's
just a throwaway line in The Matrix so
we know that's not the full truth and
it's and therefore it's
grotesque and we're talking about ego
work Shadow work I think and in the
meeting the new how many drinks do you
have in a week your doctor says how many
drinks do you have in a week and you lie
about that or the Temptation
is is how much TV does your child watch
that's the new joke that's the new
question that we're all like M so in
this meeting screen time comes up and
this
woman I was going to say God Lov this
woman [__] it let's be Wicked right
right God's tired of this woman go ahead
yeah let God saying not her again yeah
yeah there you go let's not sandpaper it
let's let the joke be the joke this
woman is talking about how uh she
doesn't her child was having a meltdown
and and wanted to watch the screen and
and but we we didn't and and it's sort
of a virtue signal we didn't do it and
valenar are sitting there being like
we'd give Leela the iPad for sure for
[__] sure
absolutely and then I was unpacking it
and I I don't want to miss the joke with
too much analysis but I was like isn't
it funny that this kill or be killed ego
thought system have either I'm esteemed
or you're not esteemed either you're
going to build up my Identity or you're
going to tear it
down I'm like she's doing it there the
thing that protecting her child from the
screen which might show her evil MH is
now being alchemized turned into evil in
this room where she's saying and I'm not
saying it's actually evil I'm just
saying it's because I it's bad it's bad
but it's it's it's it's lowgrade evil
yeah is going like and we didn't and I
know some of you would and therefore I
win and you lose and the ego has just
slightly moved up a peg yeah and I'm
like so we're even taking the things we
do to protect our children from the evil
and we using that to further our
self-image and our and our esteem if we
take that down to the yah har she's
hearing about U the kid mil she wants to
tell she wants a virtual signal yeah
right she want to hit yeah and I can't I
can't fault that but yes and the yet the
yeter har says okay listen the kid
screaming right yeah and the kid could
calm down by watching
some puzzle on the on the iPad right
yeah but you can also virtual signal
yeah now which is more important you're
virtu signaling or your kid suffering oh
interesting and she goes virtue
totally totally
let's it's like do you want one hit of
cocaine now or two tomorrow forget the
kid your kid suffering ah the kid's
suffering who cares about the kid we got
to go on there own virtue signal okay
and she's telling the joke and
everybody's going the iPad lady she goes
and I know you would and we go yeah I
would because we're not evil like you
right so you really unpack this I mean
it's that I mean so when people say how
when I'm doing my parenting classes so I
do I do this
disruptive technique how much how many
hours a day should my kid be on their
screen I said as much as they want they
go what I said okay so prove me wrong I
put the onus on them we're not going to
sit all at all virtue signal that our
children ought not what they want to do
as long as they're not hurting anybody
yeah so now we're now we're going to
dial that back is it safe is it healthy
are there other things they should be
doing what's the price of conflict what
do we have in mind there's a whole other
thing sure but the minute you say
there's a natural god-given limit on
kids enjoying themselves you're so right
on by the way you're doing what the
rabbi and the joke could have done what
do you mean by going yeah right because
in the same
conversation uh someone was like cuz
there are studies that this and that and
I was like and there are studies
that say whiskey is good for you like
who's who's funding the study what is
the like the fear-based paranoid like a
you're telling me a researcher it
couldn't be fear-based and paranoid and
and taking a best shot at looking at the
data and and and what I'm saying is we
don't know the absolute truth and you're
shining a light comically on that yeah
yeah and what I say to people about the
kid with the screens I say what is your
overall goal of parenting this is the
foundation of my parenting
class uh tg's good habits I said among
them but questionable because we don't
yet know what a good habit is because if
you're going to say it's good we should
have some sense of what the overall good
is now let's get back to my question do
you have an overall good under which all
the minor Goods fit so let's discuss the
overall good what are you aiming
at that's very interesting do you want
me to play along yeah sure because there
is like a this
idea it's so fun cuz Val and I love at
the end of Leela goes to bed and we
watch a movie or something it's [__]
great yeah and yet I so I can even judge
myself I go aren't there better happies
than than just that happy no I know
that's what I'm saying that's what I
feel you walking me towards but I think
I might have a belief that there's a
better Happy a richer happy that I want
to force and we're we're not strict but
but that I want to force my daughter to
pursue like you should never do that Val
and I shouldn't watch a movie when Leela
goes to bed we should go on a hike and
write a song and read Tolstoy and we
should uh dance always and when I heard
that story I was like I I don't know
what the data is but when I they
actually there is some data Rob Bell he
had a a surfing accident and he was like
all he wanted to do was watch TV and
somebody explained that to him is that
his Theta brain w like there's a re
regenerative like it's not quite asleep
it's not quite awake but his brain was
kind of like healing while was doing
that that's exactly what a lot of
Television does right okay in defense of
Television folks yeah no I my wife and I
we we love good television yeah I mean
we it it it is for us it's the best yeah
so isn't it funny because Val and I
agree with you and we here going I mean
when when when I watched Breaking Bad
the fifth time yeah I just felt lucky to
be alive when breaking bad was out I
mean when I watch the wire for the
fourth time yeah Sopranos for the 10th
time yeah um I there's some stuff out
there that that I mean has hit to the
heart of The Human Condition with and
what it took to get that out the hours
and hours for each scene and the writers
and the and the casting and the
directors I mean it's it's a Monumental
effort to deliver deep meaning over to
the viewer and I'm standing in awe of
art yeah so yeah yeah right right ohh
this is good stuff so so with our kids
by the way so when I saw these bow kind
of turning Minds into oatmeal
cartoons uh I always look for something
that had an edge so when they start
watching dector dector laboratory you
ever see that okay that's that's that's
a nice little edgy show interesting so
we would look for that and then we
introduced him to the Mark Brothers okay
oh wow and they liked it oh they
couldn't get enough of the marks
Brothers okay I feel like because the
humor yeah tell is physical right and
then it's always making fun of somebody
some sty character uh the fourth marks
brother is is typically the butt of the
jokes
then you move forward and they're always
making jokes about
language so um somebody walks in and
says grouo glad to see you back this is
my front that's my back buddy I'm look I
I don't want to ruin the joke by over
philosophizing it but like you're
talking about matter so you know like a
guy moving a piano up up a staircase is
fair and we need it we're stuck in this
and we're also stuck in language and
language this is not not a pipe right so
this isn't these are just sounds and
it's not quite reality and we need to
laugh at it it's important is that kind
of what we're the mark brothers are
deconstruct all mores they deconstruct
language they deconstruct Customs so
it's it's a constant act in Breaking
Reality Part and getting a huge laugh
out of it now it's it's inherently
pleasurable and then you're the I'm the
kind of guy that sits back and say why
was that funny m let me figure this out
and there's all kinds of other agendas
they have it is when you look at the
agendas of the Marx Brothers there's
some deep social political philosophical
things going on in the uh I don't doubt
in the Mark Brothers anyway so um as far
as our kids tell when they would sneak
television we called him one time I said
what are you watching and they said uh
I'm looking I said that a police show he
said yeah because they're like 11 and N
what is it it's called Law and Order I
never watched it so I said let me see it
and that it's Law and Order Order
Special Victims Unit yeah so this says
PG13 parent advisory and I'm looking at
it I'm looking at think to myself okay
you have to watch this every single day
for the rest of your lives why because
there are predators out there wow You'll
appreciate this they don't we don't
teach stranger danger anymore and I I
hope you like this I say to my daughter
because I I read it somewhere which
means Instagram I said um you got to
look out for tricky people and chances
are you know the tricky person so only
Mommy and Daddy can touch your body you
always and no one can ask you to keep a
secret from us and then Leela goes yeah
cuz some people might take me away and
put me in a cage right there you go and
I go what the like she's not watching
Special Victim Unit but she was with it
cuz she's not as sandpaper down I don't
know I I can't even pretend to
understand that yeah so we've talked
respect yeah um how to be present and
how to read all the signals yeah so look
that's that's a lifetime of parenting
you know 360
awareness be a respectful present kid
watch out for the evil people that's
that's a lifetime of parenting it's it's
a lifetime for a person but as far as
the the video games
go uh I this this one parent in class
was having a raging argument with this
kid and I said what's the video game
first of all because there are there are
some that require dexterity skill
planning strategy with Incredible music
in the background by the way better than
any of the stuff you and art video games
are art exactly so I'm looking for the
downside and the dad says well I don't
know he keeps wanting to tell me about
it and I'm going okay let me just revive
myself your son is doing something he
loves that has strategy and art did you
see Gran Turismo it's the movie about
the guy who was obsessed with Gran
Turismo and then he became a real race
car driver uh and it's a similar father
being like I don't understand this game
and like at the end of the movie he bet
he does the last time I got a clue I
watched
um uh the one with Kate blanch at tar
tar tar uhhuh yeah remember the last
scene I haven't finished oh my God I got
to watch it from the beginning with my
wife watch it from the beginning I'm not
going to spoil it for you yeah but it is
one of the most RI riveting movies I've
ever watched I was on the edge of my
seat almost fainting every 20 seconds
that we're going to watch it tonight oh
you just got to be ready yeah that it is
so sneaky wow that if if you're really
watching it very carefully yeah it's
just pulling you along relentlessly to
your demise wow so that's how I watched
it in that's how I felt with succession
by the way I go it was all leading to
this there was one episode in particular
I was like it was all a long setup for
this episode and we're all freaking out
no one's talking we're all holding our
breath I was like these sons of [__]
three seasons just going like yeah it's
a fun show about rich people
like it's incred I I haven't been able
to watch it I will I know you and
everybody I admire plus you they're all
telling me I gota watch yeah yeah yeah
no you're Absolut so anyway so when
someone says video games I'm thinking to
myself what exactly you talking about
the fact that is that that it is kind of
two-dimensional is that is that your
problem like what's what's your anims
toward it yeah and then I have to unpack
their well it's a waste of time I said
by what you mean this mindless homework
about the ES girl who overcome great
challenges to get on the Eskimo Squad
whatever yeah and you read the same
basically the same story every year
since second grade about the oppressed
kid and there's nothing subtle they're
clearly pushing some kind of agenda that
we should be nice to people don't look
like us got that memo yeah now what is
going to make my kid deeper not just
know to be a good person which they
actually know from the home
anyway and I'm waiting for them to teach
something like Lord of the Flies yeah
right interesting now that's you know
some some version of that when I was a
kid about fifth grade wrote a book
called The Forgotten door by Alexander
key okay a kid from another planet
suddenly arrives at a small town in in
in the
Appalachia that was interesting to watch
a kid with superpower shows up in
Appalachia wow now you know a Black Or
Hispanic kid showing from Appalachia
that's one thing a kid with superpowers
and the way you want to kill that kid
yeah the whole town eventually wants to
kill the kid then you have to figure
that out wow okay so if and now if a VD
if a video game can deliver
over strategy depth surprises great
music great yeah you know then then but
and then people say well how long I said
talk to the kid just talk to your kids
say do you want to pass third grade
fourth grade eighth grade yes what do
you got to do to pass eighth grade I got
to do this are you getting that done yes
yeah are you getting enough sleep
because we have to make sure that you
are physically mentally morally healthy
and you need sleep do you know about
sleep yes so would we agree that you
need x amount of sleep to be healthy so
you for your immunity system yes let's
figure all the things you got to do yeah
this is called um uh uh setting up a
schedule which is the great one one of
the greatest gifts you can give your kid
is to know that um uh calendar is King
and clock is Queen you got to live
inside that that's what we started
saying it's like why are we doing CU
this is the time that we do this because
this is the time we do it yeah so let's
schedule your day and let's put in as
much video time as we can I'm on your
side I want you to enjoy your life wow
now and people say well I haven't been
doing that I said go to apologize to
your kid give him this new attitude come
back to class they come back to class
and they say my kid was
shocked grateful they felt I was on
their side for them to enjoy their life
I said now you're getting the long goal
of parenting which is yeah which is when
they're 20 and lost really lost they'll
call you wow that's one goal appearent
wow of
course whoa okay I'm with you by the way
because I played Call of Duty I'm
assuming it's some game like Call of
Duty or fortnite or something like that
where you're shooting
people and
the I don't want this to sound can but
my roommate and I became closer because
of it and we were it's basically we were
playing the flag and I understand that
it's violent and you know there's
there's Graphics that are you know
grotesque maybe but it was not that's
not how I remember it no you remember
the camaraderie yeah uh safer than
football safer than football so I was on
a panel once about violence and video
games and you know when you've been
around violence violence yeah it's
different nobody's watching video games
in Compton yeah to encourage them right
to beat up white kids yeah right and of
all the white kids playing video games
how many are actually going out and
beating people up there's no evidence
whatsoever if someone says well I want
them to have the images I say okay let's
have a talk about that but video games
don't lead to violence and violence
doesn't come from video games let's just
establish that because there's been
violence long before there were a video
game right so let's let's just figure
that out now what is the attraction
especially of boys to Danger yeah it's
genetic right because if you didn't have
boys that could stand up to Danger the
tribe would have been annihilated right
you have to have some number of people
who
will Who will uh obey the Call of Duty
and they need to do it imaginatively
great right and to your Lord of the
Flies point and to your football point
this is again let's not sandpaper it
down let's talk about opposition and
let's talk about pain and human
depravity and how you face human
depravity and right so there's so many
deeper questions that um you know that
that
in my parenting the soul class if if a
parent had problem with Call of Duty I'd
say you can play as much as you want
that's my that's my first thing so we're
not having an argument here you're not
bad I'm we're not going to play I'm good
you're bad I need to school you yeah
because that's no way to set things up
with a kid tell me about it I want to
understand what you love about it okay
and because when the kid says okay I can
do that you're developing Insight now
Insight is a gift for Life long after
you don't play Call of Duty yeah you
will have been trade for insight so
that's actually the the the one of the
uh kind of hooks for my class yeah
Insight is a gift for life every problem
you have with a child is a chance to
teach insight to say explain to me your
resistance to to brushing your teeth you
don't have to brush your teeth first of
all we're not going to fight about that
I want you to go inside and tell me why
it's meaningful for you not to brush
your teeth yeah and we're back to me
yeah no one tells me what to do yeah
exactly so you go inside and say of an
oppositional part of me that needs a day
off so I can do all my other stuff yeah
and you say that's all you need for me
to get everything else done yeah yeah
take it yeah yeah
okay I feel like I know the answer but
let's talk about it because this is a
hoot and a privilege to talk with you
about this but my daughter first of all
I'm going to say why do you love teenage
meet Ninja Turtles but that's been a
thing that's been a daddy daughter thing
and it's a show that I with my eyes open
was like there's weapons there's kicking
there's punching there's language like
uh Stupid um trying to think of anything
idiot might show up idiot actually shows
up in a lot of Disney movies you
wouldn't think so there's L there's a
little bit of language and there's bad
guys I'm watching it with again it's
it's this precious thing to me we're
sitting there and we always kind of
snuggle when we watch it and she's not a
huge snuggler so it's like a ritualistic
kind of like Dad show nice and yeah and
there's Shredder and he's covered in
knives and he's a bad guy and there's a
scene where he kicks the butt of every
turtle and they're you know it's in a
cartoon way but they're laying down
there she's like what happened to
Raphael and I'm like you got
electrocuted if you touch electricity
you get shocked and you'll you might die
but that's how we talked to her by the
way and that's how she talks I think she
was a hunter in a past life she's like
what's chicken exactly I go someone
killed a chicken and uh and we eat its
body and she goes I want to kill a
chicken that was that's how she
responded so I've been like in awe of
her so anyway going to the Ninja
Turtles Val and I again we're new this
is our first kid we're like is this okay
and we've started to kind of move away
from Ninja Turtles and Leela's really
going I want to watch Ninja Turtles if
I'm picking up what you're laying down I
should talk to Leela like what do we
like about Ninja
Turtles can you tell me what you like
about Ninja Turtles exactly and again I
feel like you'll appreciate this Lea and
I do this and and we and we fight each
other and I flip her and I throw her she
gets hurt and we've changed the language
of when she gets hurt I go you got
gnarled I go you got gnarled and it's
like it's like a good thing she's like I
got gnarled yeah it's different from
getting hurt all great stuff yeah all
great stuff okay and it seems to me I'm
going to go home to Val and be like we
need to talk to Leela about Ninja
Turtles and watch Ninja Turtles with her
and does it make does it make you scared
yeah does it make you scared no and if
it does why you like feeling scared
because that's also part of that's what
I meant to tell you we're watching
Shredder kick everyone's but and after
the scene she goes I kind of like
Shredder mhm I was like of course you
like Shredder the bad guy is so exciting
he's so dangerous he's cool and you know
so that I mean to go to a union level
there's a she has a
fantasy of her capacity for violence
yeah and that's one thing was
is you know people have that part of
them
suppressed uh I remember uh when I was
in rabinal school all these years ago I
taught Holocaust for many years and I
had a rabinal student and I said this
isn't everybody she says it is not in me
I that is has nothing to do with who I
am I said I think it's in everybody she
says no it is not in me wow I said okay
I'm taking your word for it I hear years
later that she quit she went moved to
another city and quit rabinal school
won't be a rabbi anymore I thought she
was a really really great person so she
got on the phone and I said why'd you
quit retical school she said because you
were right I discovered there is a
there's a
horrible disgusting side of me and I am
unconscious I didn't feel worthy to be a
rabbi what I want to say is now you're
worthy to be a rabbi that's ex I got
chills that's exact so I yeah okay if
there's an opening here I couldn't wait
to say this our whole thing going back
to I started saying this before I told
you the iPad violence the the micro
violence of that that's not even what I
mean I just mean the ego trip of it yeah
my my whole spiritual practice these
days is going and my comedy it's not
around it's through I tell this story I
just started telling the story and
you'll I think you'll appreciate this I
want to I want to name the the the yet I
want to I might just say my before this
conversation I might have just said my
ego call the resistance the resistance
or the or the Shadow the shadow because
you're let's say your ego is comprises
all of them I'm with you and sometimes
when the jokes don't work I go if you
guys aren't laughing you need to do
what's known as Shadow work and like
that gets a laugh uh but so I started
getting more I've been doing stand up
for 20 years plus and now I'm drawn more
to things like this so I'm telling this
story I'm pushing Leela on the
swing and there's this little girl and
I'm playing with all the kids and and
I'm going like my name what's your name
my name's Mr Chicken head and everyone's
laughing and we're having fun then this
kid just starts calling me Mr poo poo
and part of the joke is that I'm like I
was shocked at how much it hurt my face
feelings like there was this like Rush
of like you got disrespected man yeah
she was disrespecting me yeah that's
going to make the story even worse but
that is how I felt and you also have no
recourse other than like I tried all the
strategies I was like I am Mr poooo like
owning it yeah or uh that's that's the
one I chose I was like sure I'm Mr poooo
but then she dug in and she just going
poo poo poo poo I was like ah yeah so
then I was just like in my mind pure
Shadow just being like well then [__]
you like I'm trying to get a party going
and you ruined it yeah this is pure
Shadow and I know you're going to love
it cuz you've done this work and this is
what I'm trying to do in my I'm trying
to elevate it to Art I want to get art
right later she's walking in front of
the swings and a kid my kid goes flying
into her you know how kids are always
walking too close to the swings I it was
too late Leela was out of my hand she
walked in front gets hit and I go there
was a part of me that goes you know like
just a little
well who's the only fault who's Mr poooo
now who The Only Fault in what in what
you just told yeah tell me you should
have set that up set what up for bumping
into the kid I should have done it
yeah it was God buddy in my notes I
wrote and I because whether or not the
way the story actually happened and this
is Artistic Liberty was that Leela had
been pushed yeah in the joke I would say
and I didn't do it on purpose and then I
go I might have done it a little bit on
purpose like just a little bit of me was
like I you see how this goes when you
how would do it yeah I'd say I I I
didn't mean it I push her knock the kid
down and say okay so now I'm coming
clean I did push it I did I did I did it
that's exactly right you're exactly
right that is the
form full respect I go I didn't do it I
because and okay because the kid
deserved
it you don't call adults Mr poooo and
whoever brought her up they didn't teach
her so you might have to in some kind of
relatively n violent way teach this kid
there are boundaries including don't
disrespect adults because you might get
killed if it were a different adult
right oh interesting you went to a
different Park in a different part of
town uh yeah you might yeah something
you might really get hurt that's really
interesting I never even thought about
that that's what I think about why the
you pull that you can pull that off in
West LA don't pull it off three miles
south of here right and and it was in LA
and it wasn't a night it was over in
Griffith Park so it would have been like
different in a different area you're
absolutely right some other adult would
knock that kid in the next week and not
thought about it twice right a crazy
yeah well we and someone else would say
thank you for doing that to my kid right
interesting I do want to say my own
sensitivity wants to say the kid was
fine that happens n every parent knows
that happens 9,000 times a day yeah it
it does it does but see for me there's a
deeper issue that when the kid when the
kid says poooo head
yeah they're they're saying to them I'm
going to disrespect an an adult and
there's nothing they can do and they and
they know that that's what felt so
wicked about it I was like and you see
now now plant that seed yeah plant that
seed and see if that seed grows so I'm
going to tell you something
horrible uh I'm picking my my kid up
from uh Middle School um for whatever I
need to talk to the vice principal and
there's other kid sitting now he said
what happened and the kid had a bad
mouth on him and um that he like really
cussed out a
teacher and he said um his friend says
so what are they going he going to call
my mom what's your mom goes nothing man
I'll cuss her out too I'll beat her ass
and then I said okay so this kid's going
to kill somebody because he's already
eighth grade and he's completely under
restraint and when he said that I've
seen some big middle schoolers do
exactly that to their dad we had a
neighborhood we lived in we we had kids
had a friend in sixth grade I saw them
in eighth grade running down the street
jumping on top of cars like he would go
from car hood jump on the the the like
the top car and just running down the
street jumping on cars and denting the
hoods and the hoods over the engines and
I'm looking at them I think to
myself um look it might be genetic it
might be
sunspots but it could be the fact that
you know I we knew his mom a lovely
person but single mom too much on her
hands and I thought this is a tragedy
because he's going to do that to
somebody yeah who's not going to want it
to happen right so that's what I say to
kids these kids a little bit a little
bit out of control I say listen you need
to know you can do that where you live
you do it in the wrong place at the
wrong time it's not going to end well so
you might want to learn to stop doing it
now I just I just apply to their
self-interest that's really interesting
I mean I appeal to their self-interest
yeah so this this little girl I mean
look we're we're in the realm of Comedy
here and and but I worry for that little
girl yeah see a little girl who feels
free to do that yeah I worry for her
yeah it's interesting because plant the
seed that's something you taught me uh
in insight yeah huge planting the seed
and kind of taking it out and Buddy
literally just now I've been like right
we're not just raising our daughter for
our
neighborhood I know that's embarrassing
but I don't mind being embarrassed like
I here's another example my daughter
punches me and I you know again we're
just messing around and I like that and
then when we go see the grandparents I
have to go like and whenever she hits me
or we're playing I go you can hit data
don't hit anybody else
because it's an understanding I told you
this is a signal that means we're
fighting and then she did kick my dad
and my dad who grew up in a different
time and I'm so glad she didn't see it
but he gave her what I would call the
death look the like don't [__] with me
like no no filtering of it for the child
version yeah and and I'm trying to have
compassion for my dad my dad grew up in
a tougher neighborhood situation where
you couldn't let that stand and I'm like
it's my daughter who cares you you're
lucky to be kicked by her but you're I'm
seeing there's different yeah and and
that's a discussion I with your daughter
see if I if that were my kid who have
done that to you yeah I would said I
would have said first of all I'm please
forgive my child and please forgive me
yeah so kid we need to talk first of all
you're not in trouble yeah you're not in
trouble I want to know what went through
your head yeah where of all the things
in the world you could have done that's
what made sense yeah yeah or or your
daughter you right but going back
because yeah and the kids go Oh I don't
know I just felt like it
clearly but I want you to go deeper yeah
and you're not in trouble yeah you're
not in trouble not going to punish you
but you need you need to have insight to
what you did because it wasn't right
this is Grownups this is um Louis CK
Scandal noted had a a great bit about
shut up and eat your [__] french
fries and like what a lot of grown-ups
aren't doing is like why it wasn't the
french fries like you're not mad about
what you I say this all the time because
I I want to get it out as much as I can
in my marriage
some of the most helpful language that
I've discovered is um I was just
embarrassed and that I don't know if I'm
an archetypal man or whatever but it's
usually something threatened my sense of
self and wellbe and my value that no one
intended and then something maybe or
maybe they did and then it comes out in
this other way and and Val is a genius a
love genius so she'll be like what's
going on MH and when I look in I go I
was embarrassed so my neighbor here Kate
I always joke about not my neighbor my I
guess I'd say my tenant she rents this
house I always like notice that like I
get threatened when she never knows who
the guest is she always asks and I I
always say um I joke with her I go
you're not going to know I'm GNA say
lwis black and you're going to say who
that's always what happens so I give her
[__] and that's fine but I was driving
down and I use my car time as as
thinking time and I was going like what
is the
underlying
thought an i uncovered if Kate doesn't
understand me or Kate is undermining my
value this is like really like going
like go ahead unconscious tell me in the
voice of a little child what do you
think she's undermining my value if she
doesn't see me I'm not safe all of this
stuff comes out and as soon as you look
at it you can go
that's ridiculous and I was a lot kind
of gentler coming incredible
work when you realize if if if you're
not recognize let's say um the quality
of a guest yeah right somebody that that
should know which reflects on your
stature yes exactly and we we that's
part of our core needs as a human being
is to have our stature respected right
in fact that's one of the greatest
causes for anger and violence is to have
your stature disrespected okay that's
exactly right it's a core need so so if
she doesn't know who's coming in I feel
my stature disrespected therefore I have
completely human reaction of threatened
because if you don't respect my stature
now we go down to the primate level yes
you're going to take my mate you're
going to take my food you're going to
make my territory right yes okay I'm
telling you yes right and then you
realize and you say oh you yeah yeter
har yeah you got in me yeah okay so now
let me tell you something yet a she
actually is not on this planet to watch
out for my stature that's right I'm good
and she's not the Arbiter of my value he
exactly right he goes he goes yeah
you're
right he does yeah but and like an
insulin child he just needed the shadow
just needed me to look at it and ackn
that's a great way to put it because see
that's for me that's that
cabalistic the shadow is symptom ising
your Brokenness and asking you to look
at it so you can repair yourself now
that that's deeper level that's deep
stuff no it is at a at a basic level
it's your alternative self making a
making a a play for power I hear that
yes but at a deeper level yes or the
deeper level the reason I'm a
comedian I I think one of the reasons
I'm a comedian is is because I started
feeling like if I'm not seen I'm not
safe sort of thing and so I go on stage
it's brilliant actually as a strategy as
a psychological strategy talk and do it
in a funny way so they laugh and you
know they heard you and you kind of like
get that wound kind of patched over yeah
I I tell jokes all the time I populate
my sermons my teachings with humor and
and I realize one thing it is when you
get a laugh out of
somebody um you feel like you're you're
you you're in charge of the room and
you've brought pleasure and Delight to
everybody you really it's a really it's
a really great feeling and um uh so I
then I have to look at myself and I'm
saying is it is it really for the sake
or am I just seeking attention and he go
yeah a little bit seeking attention I
said okay how much you know I had a a I
had a spiritual teacher and um he sent
me out to speak in his in his stad
on and I have my natural ability and
very highly trained by him I went out to
a university and gave a talk I came back
said how'd it go I said horrible he said
why I said because I I enjoyed it too
much man I just had they were in the
fall of my hand yeah he said um here's
the rule he said if it's if it's ever um
less than uh 10% for God and 9% for
morai don't do it at least a
tithe tithe are better tither better yes
but if it's not 10% at least 10% for God
then stop talking I love this and then
he said okay if it's ever all for God
you in really you're in really big
trouble cuz you're lying that's the
twist cuz you're lying every time you
tell a or joke or like a wisdom thing
thing I I get the stomach flip cuz I'm
like I didn't see it coming if it's 100%
for God you're [__] yeah you're you're
just lying to yourself yes and a Pious
liar yes oh that's a worst kind of liar
that is it yeah I again through when I
was a younger man I would say no I want
to save these people from a bad night I
want them to feel Joy and now as I'm
older I go like this is mutually
beneficial it's okay to use my wound I
need to be seen
to Delight in fact I feel like that's
pretty good alchemy yeah and you know
whenever I have a particularly good
night on or you know Friday night or
Saturday morning I say to myself 70% for
morai 30% for God I'm still in the game
still in the game and by the way I I'll
disagree with you slightly here go ahead
you see I think your talent I mean the
thought the citation your act your your
ability to connect to your unconscious
CU comment has to go straight through
you can't cogitate on everything you got
to read there's so many things going on
I mean it's a talent you know not just a
wound it's a god-given talent yeah now
you may be working with a wound but more
than anything is talent and as long as
you're not advocating violence or some
destructive Behavior there's no downside
to making people laugh in fact people
like you and I watch some of your stuff
you are the kind where a person says why
did I laugh right you're like they say
okay I just learned something about
myself oh I like that so I like I like
that kind of uh com and I when I think
to myself I only use comedy jokes Ry
comments in my teaching for the service
of the point not just to say as an aside
here's a joke I've done that by the way
right because I can't
stop that's the 70% that's like yeah I'm
down into but that goes back to the
beginning of our conversation that your
happiness that's a that's a duty you
know and you know what I I said I'm
sorry last time I just told J for jokes
say a rabbi Finley we love it when
you're having fun it was a fun joke so
or else we going to hear jokes if you
don't tell them to us and then what is
the underlying message of you having fun
right yeah that's a valuable that's like
saying the underlying value of saying
what do you like about Call of Duty is
let's teach you Insight but seeing a a
member of the clergy having fun and
being light and being present and just
kind of wanting to that's what they say
to me I thank you for that because they
say you're having fun yeah and we're
having fun and you don't always have to
be on topic you don't always have to be
on yeah sometimes you can free associate
tell us a joke come back yeah and we're
all good well I would attest to that
being very true because that's what
you're doing now yeah I I'll throw this
at you people uh always think I'm a
clean comic and I'm like I say [__] all
the time but that I think there's
something interesting there is like the
the being fun and present and light and
not ugly the word I use is ugly not
dirty or clean but like are you being
ugly is communicated in a way that
transcends logic meaning like I love I
love clean comics and they just watched
me say all these swear words and talk
about sex or whatever it is and I'm like
that's exactly where I'm trying to go
you know what I mean sure and uh by the
way I mean I watch the raunchiest comics
I I will never use a vulgar word yeah I
will never make fun of any group other
than Jews yeah and will never let
anybody else do in my presence yeah now
within that a lot of funny stuff I was
going to say that's a rich culture to be
able to and I i' I've always admired the
self-deprecating and and just the
shorthand not every Jew obviously not
every Jewish person but yeah you got a
you got a good field yeah thank you I
have I mean when I po when I teach my
wisdom classes I always populate it with
an you know a uh anecdotes that are
hilarious clearly I I've washed them
through the the the test of
anonymity but man there's some hilarious
things that happen when you cancel
people the the cluelessness that people
people Evin and they're just you know
when I was teaching my Hebrew school
back in the day
um uh I was tried to teach them wisdom
through anecdotes and I'd have them on
the floor laughing about people like
their parents so one way I got them to
behave was they say more anecdotes more
anecdotes more couns more couns I said
as a reward if you pay attention yeah so
they would pay they would pay attention
so then I could do my half hour of
standup with the seventh grade right
great and they they loved it so teaching
wisdom through anecdotes and hilarious
anecdotes and and they stick with people
yeah people years later come to me say I
will always remember the point you made
when you taught that well isn't it funny
that you said plant that seed and I saw
you used your thumb and I saw your thumb
pushing a seed down and I'm like that's
what I'll remember at the swings you
know I mean images stories these things
stick to us so much more even sitting
here at the beginning of our
conversation I was like quick Pete
against status looking for me being
special think of those interesting
things you know about the Jewish faith
yeah and and say
them yeah right and who cares the reason
I can't even think of them too is
because like you know there's that
there's slogan and really great slogans
or really great oh did you know this or
that but the stuff that really sticks is
like a story you said Lord of the Flies
and a whole feeling wash over me right
yeah it's crazy you know when uh so
here's a good little inside thing about
Jewish religion yeah um people say uh we
only believe in one God I'll say Jews
today why do Jews only believe in one
God they actually don't believe in any
God but at least one is the
minimum I'm not going to believe in any
God that's just I just keep it to one do
you run into a lot of Atheism in yeah
that's that's like a like I uh Jewish
values Jewish culture and I say so what
what's your culture yeah or I don't mean
that many cultured people
right it well in in the Christian
tradition you call that uh Easter
Christmas Christian exactly yeah is that
is that Christian culture I guess I
don't know I don't know doesn't sound
like culture to me it's not it's barely
what do you make for because atheism I
forget where I learned this but it was
like it's a pretty modern phenomenon
yeah the this idea and I always think of
pendulette who is a just I always say
he's a gorgeous atheist I I I love him
he's he's really almost like a Mystic
meaning he's resting in the I don't know
he's not saying he he'll tell you he's
like could there be a God yeah maybe I
am saying there's no evidence I don't
see the evidence but he's saying my flag
says I don't know and then he explains
why that's not agnosticism agnostics
believe that they don't believe it's
possible he's saying whatever whatever
it is who cares it's boring we just lost
the joke but like so there's that I
guess what I'm I'm putting it to you
what what you make for all the atheism
is it suffering is it no it's the
enlightenment I mean people rightly
blasted the dogma of the church as
untenable for first of all the
Scientific Revolution and then the
Enlightenment and so forth it just
wasn't tenable it was not sustainable
yeah and religion was very slow on his
feet uh to go where they went in the
20th century was the understanding of
human consciousness so they have a young
coming back in makes a strong case for
religion but then you had to read Yung
meaning that language is metaphoric
language is imagistic we're not reading
the Bible could is the very word of God
because it is rich in an understanding
of uh The Human Condition and metaphors
for Consciousness so he say to me is it
from God I said I don't know there's
people touched by God who wrote some of
this stuff but that's not I mean I read
it for a few reasons number one I'm part
of a people it's our inheritance there's
been great Labor and sacrifice to pass
the Bible and the tulet and all of it
down um it's amazing it's beautiful it
binds me to other people we have a an
ongoing conversation so if I say to
somebody job we're already talking right
um if I say to someone from China and
they say what are you studying job
what's that right the Bible what's that
right so yeah I can do it but I'd rather
actually be someone you know that we're
all we're already in in the conversation
so part of I see Judaism as a coherent
language value system text metaphors
ways of talking so we can conduct the
business of deep deepening and enjoying
our lives so people say do believe in
God I say what exactly do you mean
because they usually mean something that
I don't believe yes so that's what I got
to I got to clear that up now as far as
evidence see when you go to anything not
empirical for example
Justice see if you're looking for what
is the empirical evidence that the
metaphysical value of Justice exists
empirical because he says I don't see
any evidence for it I don't see evidence
for the existence of Justice either
because people are unjust so when I say
that's not
right what do I
mean yeah so whenever I hear people talk
well people have a right to do that I
said you know because I'm trained I'm
you know but doctor in religion social
ethics and I did a year of law school I
studied legal Theory so I I read books
such as what are rights where do rights
come from so when a person says well I
have a right to do it I say that's so
interesting would you like to talk about
that what is a right yeah and where do
they come from and how do you know when
they you have them yeah and what does it
license you to do or not do in other
people see people don't think about this
but
ultimately um if it's just made up
in our
culture it refers to a justification for
action but if there's something
metaphysical like in the Declaration
human beings are endowed with unable
rights but they're metaphysically OU
it's a whole other game so if I were
talking to who's who's the the the
gorgeous yeah so if he would say I don't
see any evidence for it I say can we
just forget the God thing because that's
that's that's it's actually not worth
having the
conversation do you believe that human
beings actually have
rights when we say human rights yeah is
that a is that a sensical statement to
you in what sense is it true I feel like
itd say yes okay and I'll say okay so
what is the evidence that there's this
metaphysical because it's not
empirical what is your evidence for this
metaphysical thing called rights that
human beings have right and I would be
wonder what he would say that's
interesting you want to hear my
pedestrian attempt at kind of I think
kind of what you're saying is when uh I
was flying back from Montreal and and
the flight was cancelled
and it's a temperament thing maybe it's
a a fruit of the spiritual work I've
done I don't know but I'm very good at
when things are it happened the flight
is cancelled I can just sit
down I yeah I'll I won't be plagued with
all the things I'm missing I don't
catastrophize it is what it is right it
is what it is I'm very and I my brain
again is probably wiring genetics who
knows I'll just go like oh just have to
sit in a chair uh you know I have my
book I have this there's coffee here I'm
with my friends like I just that's just
how I am it's a wonderful gift I hope my
daughter has that gift and then
meanwhile a friend of mine not a close
friend but he's up at the counter and
he's he's banging the he's pissed he's
reading the riot act to the the gate
attendant right and I'm over here going
like he's mad at United and then you
know you go on Twitter and you tweet at
United and I really just want to hear
your response wants this so I'll bring
it in pun intended for Atlantic uh I was
like United doesn't
exist there is no United there's this
plane and this engine and we can and we
like to look at patterns and go like
well this Fleet of planes statistically
has more delays and this and whatever
but like that's kind of like
a show me United we could even get
weirder and be like show me this moment
show me this room mhm I was just
laughing so hard I was like we're in
this room but to know the room you have
to kind of go around and pinch
everything to get that sensory data and
I just pinch that table so I have a
memory of it but now I'm pinching the
counts and I'm just remembering that I
pinched that and it was there so it's
like nothing is does any of that make
sense totally it's all falling apart and
we all go around going like this room
smells like ctage Che one of the core
questions of ontology the theory of
being
um and people got really stuck ever
since Aristotle so Emanuel Kant comes
along and talks about what's called
phenomenology which means the study of
perception why why in in in perception
do things organize themselves in certain
ways so he can function with the world
and you come to Hyder and so forth so
what's behind your question is a
profound philosophical discipline which
is when we say United it's a linguistic
way to organize something okay it's like
there's a company and the charter and
there's all these other people uh but
does it have a will is it conscious did
it actually do something right no yeah
it is not an independent being with the
will of its own right it's a it's a
corporate system that came down to a
person upon upon whom you can take out
your anger for something that is not
conscious and willful okay now there
might be in inefficiency somewhere but
it is not that person right so to stand
back and say you know I because I've
studied you know Theory of being like
what is and what is not um I would say
there's no conscious entity the with a
will called United produce this there's
a glitch somewhere and it might be it
might be somewhat
systemic but who wants to think that
hard well this is I'll just rather say
it's United and you're at fault yes it's
I I wrote this in my book uh Johnny
Damon I think was on the Red Sox for
many years and then I happened to be at
a ball game with my dad and then Johnny
Damon was on the Yankees and everyone
claps when he comes out and I was like
something profound is happening we're
transcending labels we know it's almost
like Soul awareness it's like Johnny
Damon as a Yankee isn't real in the same
way Johnny Damon as a Red Sox wasn't
real and we're like we have one foot in
two streams at that moment and I'm
watching I'm not putting them down but I
want to say beard swelling just because
it was like a a pedestrian kind of event
like nobody's necessarily being
philosophical but in that moment like
laughing at a joke and you don't know
why they're clapping for Johnny Damon
and it's like their love of what he was
is informing you know what I'm saying
this is great what you're saying because
human consciousness is so philosophic at
all times we're clapping because we
admire them and he used to be when he
yes yes that's deep that's deep but it's
the philosopher who unpacks it see
operate this level all the time it's
it's every day yeah so for me because I
love thinking about these things right
I've studied the philosophers who have
said let me try to explain this and and
that's why when I say I love reading
philosophy it's like somebody else
loving reading how an internal
combustion engine works right I want to
know how things work right I want to
know how Consciousness works I want to
know how jokes work yeah so um I'm going
to I'm going to give you a gift right
now it's called mining's jungle m e i n
u n g m m e i u n g u n jungle
yeah I was going to ask what should I
check out based on well just this is
just something it just occurred to me
goad so I want to put this in under your
Christmas tree I can't wait all right
it's the place where Concepts that don't
exist
exist minum jungle yeah mining am I
minum mining Is that real no it's a
mining J somebody thought it it just
doesn't correlate with anything wow but
boy did it consume our thinking
wow but so they exist but in mining's
Jungle yeah oh I like that now how many
things do people we think about stuff
but it doesn't exist yeah it does is
over there in Min Min jle min's jungle I
think I got the name right if not it's
pretty close yeah yeah but once I
discovered that concept that's like the
gift of a philosopher yeah yeah to name
the things that we think about that have
no connection with reality would United
be in that jungle well United actually
is suggested because it is a corporate
operation it is an organization it does
do business it does have parameters it
does have a function so to say it's
willful that's not such a jump yeah I
get it okay it kind of goes back to that
joke you told you work at United and you
are united you are part of United yeah
and then you're fired and now you are
not part of United but if I see you on
the street I you will still be part of
that's right yeah that's right I there
was this song I referen it all the time
I should really look up what it is but I
think this guy was on LS and he's in
Chicago and he kept touching things and
going is
Chicago is not Chicago and I'm like that
is that's philosophic man that's very
deep it's what it is right just think of
framing a picture yeah what the art
stops here yeah what exactly isn't that
amazing that your eye says here no no no
no no it's this it's this WOW or these
sounds yes craft the sounds this way
boring beautiful interesting interesting
deep just you know it's like notes and
pauses organization right how does the
brain do that I know I mean it's just I
mean I I love thinking about these
things well the prioritization of what's
important and this goes back to Stephen
pressfield the fact that your brain is
working on your next book or whatever it
might be while you're on a walk like you
go on a walk and you come back and that
problem that you had is now solved so
that let's I mean we could unpack this
that supposes that there's a part of
your awareness that is in favor of you
finishing that thing correct and it it
was effortless thinking is hard going on
a walk and just letting the background
program fix it for you was effortless so
that's sort of like seems to has a lot
of implications conscience is so
interesting is when I I sometimes give
myself a thought problem yeah and I'll
know what I think in two days wow I I'll
propose a question and tell my soul you
work on this
that's great tell me what you come up
with that's great that was in Madmen did
you watch Madmen with your great TV uh
yeah I did I loved it it's great and
there was a they're talking about
creativity and they go think really hard
about it they're trying to come up with
a slogan or something think really hard
about it for two days then put it out of
your mind there you go and I've known a
lot of people that uh maybe not a lot
but they think a problem at night and
they go to sleep and they wake up that's
why I told you I do death work at night
just there's just so much to do during
the day but my unconscious is like can
we talk about this and I'm like yeah I
made a whole special room for
you and it wants to yeah while I'm
asleep something has a want while I'm
asleep so deep right it's crazy it's so
deep it's crazy yeah yeah yeah we've hit
more than enough yeah I think we have I
feel like we hit enough this was such a
joy yeah am I using it right this was a
mitzvah for me uh Mitzvah is a duty and
that produces some good okay Mitzvah
means Duty okay obligation so not quite
right uh theyve they've wanted it to
mean a good deed yeah but a good deed is
actually good deed okay so a Mitzvah is
like when I like candle when my wife
lights candles on Friday night okay we
do it because it's a Mitzvah it's a duty
that produces a good right and there are
times when a gift you might say like
it's a Mitzvah because it was your duty
yeah yeah I see I think that's where we
started blurring the so you and I did a
Mitzvah today okay we did our you you
have a job that you love yeah and you
produce good yeah I think that's
something good to say yeah we're going
to see if we can connect that's that's
right somebody listening to that will
say wow I just had a thought I never had
and my life got a little bit deeper well
so yeah we did Adit I want to give this
to you is that I took some MDMA I know
I'm I'm the one that keeps referencing
these drugs but sometimes those hard
opening places and I'm really just
trying to give this to you okay because
sometimes Pete can get hard on himself
and and when I was in that state I was
like of all the things I'm saying this
to you now of all the things you could
do you share
and you give and that's beautiful thank
you I know that's very basic but like
when you really hear it you
go wait it's like what I felt like on
the on the experience was like I swept
the leaves away and the street was gold
and I was
like I I wish that for you I hope you
feel that today thank it's a beautiful
blessing thank you probably one of most
beautiful blessings I've ever received
appreciate it thank you that's a
blessing to me yeah well this is going
to sound silly we have the guest say
keep it crispy that's how we sign off
all right keep it signed off you say it
say keep it crispy keep it crispy is
there any way to say it in Hebrew I'd
have to really think about that not just
the words but the intent no I know a
lotka is
crispy okay we're out of here keep it as
unto a lotka that's what say keep it as
unto a lka is yish not e oh [__] see
we'll get there we'll get there we'll
get there I'm a new student okay and how
do I take your parenting course oh it's
online just go to Rabbi finley.com and
cuz I think everyone listening is going
to look that up yeah rabf finley.com I'm
in the middle of it now so it might be
gone but we're going to put up on
teachable or something okay I have
wisdom courses that I again people say
are life-changing yeah so I was ill for
I had a I got sick and I had heart um
heart B P surgery I've been recovering
for many months I've been off for close
to a year yeah so I'm just getting back
now wow and putting very glad you are
putting stuff back up there that's great
well we're going to I'm going to watch
it with my wife and I'm going to watch
Ninja Turtles with my send you the link
how's that please send me the link all
right so happy to be in touch thank you
you
it
it you made it you made it you made it
with oh yeah you made it you made it you
made it with oh yeah you made it you
made it you made it
all